[Music]
today in waltham at home cooking is all
about wonderful light dishes packed with
flavor one of the tricks to making great
food at home is having a range of
different dishes up your sleeve
sometimes you want food that's rich and
comforting other times you want to keep
it nice light and fresh it's all about
making your cooking interesting so get
ready for plenty of zingy citrus flavors
these are my ultimate light recipes
first up a lovely light breakfast of
avocado on sourdough toast with lemon
and black sesame sprinkle
light healthy quick but so tasty
for lunch an incredible mackerel ceviche
with grapefruit and shea fennel salad
that cured lightly pickled ceviche
flavour is incredible serve with
delicious super healthy quinoa salad no
wonder i'm so thin
and holly shows off her cooking prowess
when we team up to cook dinner good girl
you're faster than jack don't tell him
for starters a feta and watermelon salad
i know you're dying to get in there
aren't you
four main griddle chicken thighs with
chickpeas and a lemony dressing oh that
juicy amazing chicken and for dessert a
cool soothing lemon and basil granita
how gorgeous is that
three great tasting like meals to leave
you feeling refreshed and satisfied
through breakfast lunch and dinner
starting with a breakfast that won't
weigh you down
sourdough bread with crushed avocado
you think of the
flavor and the texture of avocado rich
phenomenal i want to make it a little
bit more vibrant
black sesame seeds a nice pinch of chili
flakes i quite like it hot
a touch of salt
and a touch of pepper
so that nice dry combination of the
lemon zest black sesame seeds and the
heat the chili this is light healthy
quick
but so tasty
sourdough bread
three nice chunky thick slices open them
up
lightly season them
little touch of olive oil
brings the whole crust to life rub all
that seasoning in
but you can use tea batter you can use
a baguette but the richness from the
sourdough or the silky creaminess of
avocado is mind-blowing and then get the
grill up to temperature and push these
down
go the extra mile we've all put bread in
a toaster but the difference
of grilling the bread this way
is extraordinary that nice smoky
charcoal flavor
off with the gas beautiful
now the avocado you've got to treat them
with love respect
press on the end here as your thumb
softens you can tell that avocado's ripe
never press here you just end up
bruising it
slice down until you feel that stone in
the middle and then just roll around and
then it's just a little gentle twist
off
stone
and out cut them into quarters the back
of your knife
peel back that skin if the avocado is
nice and ripe it should just all fall
away
slice
just take your quarters fan them out
and push them into the bread
the ripe riper the avocado the better
the flavor but look for ones free from
soft spots and blemishes which can
suggest bruising
get your lemon
squeeze
that will stop the avocado from
discoloring and then get your crunch
ready to go on top
sprinkle
in a very
generous
light way you've got the fragrance from
the lemon zest
the crunch from the sesame seed the heat
that little chili flake which just wakes
up that avocado
they look
expensive
that for me
is a delicious light start to the day
avocado on sourdough toast with lemon
and black sesame sprinkle
[Music]
next i'll be showing you a stunning
light lunch and dinner but first here's
a quick guide to some of the key
ingredients you'll need to make them
[Music]
with this unique tanky sharp lemony
flavor sumac is a prized spice used to
bring life to many mediterranean and
middle eastern dishes
whole crushed or ground sumac berries
can be added to marinades dressings
sauces or yogurt
[Music]
in its dry powdered form sumac will add
a kick to salads chicken or fish dishes
but use this powerful spice sparingly a
sprinkling is enough
along with olive oil and uzo feta cheese
made from sheep's milk or sheep and
goat's milk is one of greece's most
famous exports
like bread creeks will serve feta
alongside most meals
with a strong salty flavor it's used to
season and enrich slow cooked meats
stews and cut into rustic chunks along
with cucumber tomato and olives feta
puts the greek in gutsy greek salad
i'll be making a fruity light peta salad
for dinner tonight
[Music]
regarded as a mother grain of the
ancient peruvian inca tribes quinoa has
been grown in the high andes for
thousands of years easy to prepare its
fluffy texture and subtle nutty flavor
makes it an excellent alternative to
rice or couscous
[Music]
this small gluten-free seed was recently
hailed as an international superfood
not only does it contain all eight
essential amino acids
but it's packed with fiber phosphorus
magnesium and iron
when i first started cooking
professionally pretty much all the
high-end british restaurants serve very
rich french-inspired food lots of sauces
lots of cream and butter service but
what i've tried to do in my versions is
keep the finesse and flavor but make my
food much much lighter pork collar by
looking at that level of fat in there as
well and i've done the same thing at
home too so for my ultimate light lunch
i'm using lots of raw ingredients herbs
and citrus flavors
mackerel ceviche with the most amazing
crisp delicious fennel salad mackerel is
incredible cheap but so delicious and
sufficient just means basically
marinating but the secret is in the
dressing
pink grapefruit
take the top off
and the bottom
and don't slice off too much to begin
with otherwise you'll regret it keep
your knife
nice and flat and just start peeling
twist
you see how thick the pith is just
follow with your knife
nothing worse when you're doing this it
comes out like a hexagon or a 50 pence
piece
you can do this dressing with lemons
limes oranges but there's something
quite beautiful about a pink grapefruit
turn it over
and double check a little bit there
really important to get rid of all the
pith
slice each side
of your piff that keeps all those
segments together there's the lime slice
down
slice in
give that a little stir whisk it
and it starts to separate all those
little segments
season it
olive oil
these are little fennel prongs amazing
flavor gives a really nice aniseedy
delicious freshness it always frustrates
me how many people throw that away
because the flavour in there is
fantastic in a fish stock incredible in
a vinaigrette add that in
next chopped
coriander sufficient is served in his
marinade
something quite picturesque when you see
all that glistening
save a little touch of your dressing for
the fennel
now your mackerel
it's been filleted and pin boned
rinse your knife and just slice through
bite-size chunks
ceviche is popular in spain and south
america is always made from raw fish or
seafood cured in a citrus dressing
the less you handle the mackerel the
better it is
when you start mixing up and tossing and
turning it you lose the texture
the fresher the mackerel is the better
it will taste but when you're serving it
raw like this make sure it really is
fresh out of the sea
just lightly seasoned
so that ceviche starts to cure and
marinade that mackerel
finish that with thin little shards of
pink grapefruit and then just a little
drizzle
of olive oil on top
leave that to sit
i always like marinading my mackerel
literally an hour before i want to eat
it that kind of cured lightly pickled
chiffice flavor that is incredible
to go with my ceviche for my ultimate
light lunch a beautiful quinoa salad
with amazing textures and fresh aromatic
flavors to excite the palate
add one part pre-rinse quinoa to two
parts cold water
if you're not using pre-rinsed the
quinoa grains should be soaked before
use to remove their bitter coating
bring to a simmer and cook for about 20
minutes until the water is absorbed
spoon the cooked quinoa onto a plate and
spread out to cool
[Music]
meanwhile dry roast flaked almonds in a
frying
once golden add raisins
chopped mint
and spring onions
peel strips of skin from a whole
cucumber to make stripes
then remove the seeds and chop into half
moon slices
add half cherry tomatoes and the cooled
quinoa
and gently mix in with your
fingers season with salt and pepper
dress with a good squeeze of lime and
drizzle of olive oil
finish with a few fresh mint leaves
and for my ultimate light lunch i'm
doing another delicious salad with shea
fennel
the secret here
is to peel
the outside that gets rid of that firm
skin it starts to sort of brighten up a
little bit
almost like the sun's come out
once you've discarded the outer layer
gently shave off thin strips of fennel
for your salad
the advantage of having this nice and
thin
is because it's like these wonderful
thin
fennel
crisps fragrant delicious peel them into
your iced water
this can be done a couple of hours
before you want to eat
this will preserve the fennel's fresh
flavor and make it lovely and crisp
[Music]
drain the fennel
look at it beautiful
to complement the fennel a delicious
dressing starting with chopped coriander
fennel and lime
go brilliantly well together zest over
the fennel and then use all the goodness
inside the lime
lightly season it
dress with the leftover grapefruit
marinade from the ceviche followed by a
drizzle of olive oil
it's delicious
mackerel sat marinating away a beautiful
stunning fennel salad and that goes
brilliantly well with a quinoa
packed full of flavor but
incredibly light and very healthy no
wonder i'm so thin
[Music]
when i'm developing new recipes
i take my inspiration from all over the
world
discovering fantastic new ingredients
and cooking techniques is what really
keeps me excited about food
and for my ultimate light dinner i've
put together some great flavors to make
dishes really fresh and bright
feta and watermelon salad for starters
and a beautifully light dessert of lemon
and basil granita
but we're starting with the delicious
main course griddle chicken with
chickpeas in a lemony dressing
[Music]
and holly's going to be lending me a
hand
your favorite chicken thighs first of
all
i'll turn on the grill
the reason why we're using the thighs
are you the brown meat so it doesn't go
dry
season a nice
salt pepper
olive oil
then turn them over please
come on get your hands in there good
don't worry about your nail varnish
so there's no bones in there so the
chicken will cook really quickly
why do you do it skin side down skin
side down first that will stop the
chicken from going dry and it'll get it
really nice and crispy
good
see the way it's marked the skin now
yeah got all that really nice flavor in
there as well and we'll turn them every
two or three minutes how much do you
love chicken
lots lots i'm gonna serve that some
really nice chickpeas first we're gonna
make a little dressing
okay one nice teaspoon of mustard in
please
a little bit of olive oil
a touch of salt
and pepper
give that a really good mix
and then just squeeze lots
of lemon juice in there a little taste
it's nice mmm that is delicious
now look at that chicken now
follow that beautiful nice and crispy as
well
turn the gas down now and leave that
chicken to griddle right let's get the
chickpeas done shall we yep
so we've got peculiar peppers so these
are roasted
smoked spanish peppers have a little
taste
i would like you to chop up the
kettleberries
you take off the
the top i'm gonna slice them in half
like that
wash your fingers
oh well okay
so these are small tequila peppers
yeah a little bit sweeter there you go
your fingers please
watch your fingers please tuck them in
three finger rule come on holly
you know the three finger rule
i've been telling you that since six
months old good girl you're fast aren't
he yeah in fact you're faster than jack
don't tell him
we'll get him upset shout out the
purpose then yes please thank you
good and then give it a little mix with
your fingers
please
love it run holes
come on
out out
get out every time there's food he's
always there he smells it from a mile
away
the chicken's grilling it's inside down
why is it on
skin sides out because it keeps getting
moist keeps it really nice and moist
that's right now
we'll start the watermelon salad
watermelon
feta
cucumber
pan nice and hot
get the pecans okay and just sort of
break them up
i'm going to start slicing the
watermelon
you keep the seeds in yeah these are
fine so you just make these little boats
and go around like that
now with a toasted pecans give them a
little seasoning would you please with
pepper too um no just touch your salt
thank you roll them around and just
start to see them smoking see now turn
the gas off please
we're just gonna take half the cucumber
and give that a little peel for me
please
that's a nicely dry roasted
take them off
so from there i want you then to slice
around the seeds
and that's the watery part okay we keep
that out
wash your fingers please
nice
am i still faster than jack you are
still very fast
a lot faster than jack now
cucumber on top of the meta we'll mix it
up in a minute we're going to give that
a nice little light seasoning a touch of
salt and a little touch of pepper please
crush those little bits pecans in there
fine
nice
next greek feta cheese
this is kind of easy isn't it
jack
that fat lamb snoring you gotta get him
out of here hurry up mate take him out
fat lazy lump snoring his head off come
on out
so we've got that nice juicy melon the
cucumber and now the cheese we need
something to bring it to life i'll taste
that's sumac okay that is very citrusy
we're just gonna season that
lightly
now what i want you to do is sprinkle
the pecans in there
what's that basil mint mint
minty
you get confused with battle your
boyfriend
no daddy okay good keep it that way for
another 10 years
fresh mint over
and then
a little drizzle
of olive oil okay don't mix it yet i
know you're dying to get in there aren't
you mm-hmm and just some fresh lemon
juice
why'd you roll it it starts to release
all the juice let's now feel it
so it's less firm a little bit more
squadgy
no
it's all that lemon juice coming out now
what we to do
just have a little taste
what do you taste everything yummy it's
fresh isn't it
so that's the salad done
next a refreshingly light dessert of
lemon and basil granita
start by putting the juice of seven
lemons
and the zest of one into a small pan
with a sprinkling of caster sugar
stir over a medium heat
until the sugar dissolves
dilute your granita mix with a little
water
[Music]
pour into a freezer-proof container stir
in a good handful of chopped fresh basil
and place covered in the freezer for
three hours
when the granito is frozen around the
edges lightly break up the mixture with
a fork
[Music]
return to the freezer and repeat twice
until the granita is frozen with a
granular texture spoon into chilled
serving glasses
garnish each with a sprig of basil
[Music]
amazingly light and refreshing lemon and
basil granita
with our granita and feta salad done and
the griddle chicken beautifully charred
we can put the final touches to our main
course
i'll take the chicken
look how juicy that is see what i want
you to do now with the basil yeah it's
to get the leaves i just want to tear
them in there
there you go
start lifting the chicken up please and
putting it in the chickpeas
oh that juicy amazing chicken
remember this little baby here
have a [ __ ] right
the heat of the chicken will infuse the
basil because the chicken's nice and
warm
melt the basil
and turn this salad into something
really delicious that smells so nice
doesn't it
see how we've glazed the chicken
[Music]
slide that onto our plate
how gorgeous is that
got a roasted pepper flavor
fresh basil
there's wonderful chickpeas with a cape
of aries i think jack will like this one
you think jack would like this one yeah
yeah i'm megan
until he really
interesting let's go
well done
[Music]
this is my ultimate light dinner
griddle chicken thighs with chickpeas
and a lemony dressing
feta and watermelon salad
and for a refreshingly zingy end to the
meal lemon and basil granita
jack yeah maggie
tilly
let's go
[Music]
can't wait to dig in
so pulse scale of one to ten how easy is
this ten will you be doing it again yeah
for me
excellent great colors beautiful colors
she's very good with a knife you know
seriously faster than jack faster ninja
is there a little bit of competition
going on jackie you're worried you're
being taken over by your twin
you're not going in the corner because
she's not no she's not no
tails how is it
meg is it the kind of dish you can see
cooking for your boyfriend one day
no but i remember the first dish your
mother ever cooked for me was
chicken toast
really
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you